is that it and then there's ten
questions about guys saying I'm afraid
to talk to this girl in my class how do
I do it
that's what we've been getting lately
it's a lot right let's put all those
ones in an umbrella in a package ready
to answer all of them all right you do
it young man afraid to talk to young
women mmm yeah that's hard that's hard
to be a young man that talks the young
woman is frightening yeah but I I can
say this though I was that was that guy
as well growing up and I never talked to
them and I was never with them it did
motivate me to do stand up later and
Lefty like I've figured something out
that you know but um I do regret all
those things so it's like if you don't
you're gonna regret it I think right or
no yeah I think that I think maybe look
I I think we can all agree on something
right like I'm by a long [ __ ] way the
coolest person in this room right so I'm
very cool and and here's what what makes
me very cool I'll talk to you no matter
who you are the same way if you're
Desmond Tutu Kurt Russell or a gardener
who's fixing a fountain we will get the
same respect for me yeah because you're
human being you treat human beings with
respect and expect to be treated the
same way I expect to be treated the same
way so if you're a young man and you're
nervous about talking to a young woman
maybe you could give her the information
and say I'm nervous to talk to you I
want to talk to you but I'm nervous to
talk to you because that's what you
would that that's you given first of all
you you're being vulnerable but also
what you're doing is you're treating
someone with respect with information
say look I'm nervous to talk to you and
it's so endearing and that's you're so
right tries to mask yeah like putting on
a
No yeah you'd be vulnerable no I just
tell the truth it's not so much be
vulnerable there's no act for rise just
like just be truthful yeah just be
truthful you know you are right don't
there's no magic line there's no magic
bother is a magic button but that comes
much later but the magic button is for
way later on yeah and you have to be
asked to touch it man yeah that's the
difference a great button though is it
not oh my god it sticks out like that
[Music]